hello i'm denis
the director of dune i'm happy to
introduce one of my favorite moments
from the movie which is the spice
harvester sequence where paula 3ds
encounters the deep desert of planet
iraqis for the very first time
but strangely he will feel at home like
coming back to a place he has never been
before i don't know if you ever
experienced that kind of weird
inexplicable connection
but sometimes nature can mirror our deep
need to belong to the world and that is
what this scene is about
enjoy
i discovered dune the book in my youth
and i remember being totally
fascinated by by the book by its poetry
by what it was saying about nature there
was in this book the journey of a young
man that was struggling with his
identity and the way paul finds home
through another culture to the fremen
culture for me was amazing but the
challenge in adapting dune to the screen
is how do you convey the interior worlds
of these characters and the richness of
the world that they inhabit and i think
we all wanted to reflect our times and i
think some of the themes are just so
part of the world that we're in so we
wanted to emphasize the pressing quality
of it and what we need to do to protect
what is dear to us like the environment
you've
won a still suit before no this is my
first time
your desert boots are fitted slip
fashion at the ankles who taught you to
do that
it seemed the right way
a bit cooler
are you from it
i am accepted in both siege and village
now
come and see the spy sands on which your
livelihood depends
one of my favorite idea in the book was
the way frank herbert approached
ecology for me was so fresh was super so
powerful his view of nature was
mesmerizing
frank herbert understood that water and
oil were finite resources and the people
that controlled the water the oil or the
equivalent the spice
they have power
and so arrakis was once a beautiful
green planet but as a result of all the
harvesting of spice has turned into
an incredibly
brutal beautiful but brutal place to
survive
but frank herbert knew
you have to entertain first
and then you can't just preach to an
audience about ecology or social issues
you have to have a great story
you can see the spice scattered over the
surface
the rich spice bed
by the color
if you get a little higher you'll have a
better view
we shot that attack on the spice
arvester and it was a challenging scene
because of the weather i was praying the
gods of cinema that they will bring us
good weather on that week and thank god
they were with us because it was
important for greg and i that the light
would be consistent we were shooting in
the deep desert and we had brought our
knee doppler there some part of the
spice crawler with tons of wind machines
it was just like for me pure fun because
at the end of the day that is a moment
of cinema it's a scene that requires a
lot of choreography a lot of time of
shooting but honestly those are my
favorite thing because it's it's a
sequence that just relies on cinema and
the power of the images and we had great
time shooting
you see these spotter aircraft looking
for warm sign
warm sun
a sand wave moving toward the crawler
worms travel deep but get closer to the
surface when they attack
if you are patient
you should see one because in june
rhythm is everything rhythm is life and
rhythm most important can be death too
because rhythm
attracts the worm
worm always comes always they're drawn
by rhythmic noises
why don't we just shield the crawlers
a shield's a death sentence in the
desert it attracts the worms and drives
them into a killing frenzy
is that a worm
one of the main vehicles of dune is dr
nitopter in the book it's described as a
plane that use a propelling system that
looks like a bird and it's like a kind
of challenge to bring that to the screen
because it can either look fantastic or
very silly
to make this a reality we started back
in february
2018 with vinnie and george hall came
along with them we conceptualized this
first version
of the ornithopter we had insect
references we had bird references we got
helicopter references and then as we
went along we had more angular
references for the world of doom i said
i want them to look as real as possible
i want my mother to believe that this
thing can fly for real i wanted to obey
to gravity laws i wanted to be bulky and
powerful machine that looks like a
military helicopter
calling crawler delta ajax snyder worm
sign warning acknowledge
how
north and east of you 3.7 kilometers
i remember going to london where they
were being built and thinking these
things are huge are you out of your mind
patrice and he was like no no no they
need to be believable and then when we
had this 300 ton crane dropping these
ornithopters in the desert all of a
sudden they didn't look so big because
the desert is so vast that patrice was
right they really did need to be so big
they've been constructed in such a way
that when you're next to them the amount
of detail that they have i was blown
away
to your really contact in five minutes
so what happens now
they'll call a carry-all to lift the
crawler
they'll harvest right up to the last
minute calling carry all alpha zero
ready for docking sequence
contact five minutes
when i decided to make dune my only
condition was
that i wanted to shoot in a real
environment yeah it's insane landscaping
it's insanely beautiful
there it is
i had done in the past a movie that i
had shot in jordan and i remember saying
to myself wow if ever i make a tune
that's where i'm coming because the
landscape are unbelievably powerful and
the light is
mesmerizing the light is absolutely
unique it feels like there's something
beyond us in the soil and the air in the
sky so it feels like there's very much a
spirituality that exists there
prepare to be airborne in 30 seconds
initiated brace yourselves
what is going on
[Music]
we were trying to be intimate with
people we were trying to hear people's
quiet discussions we felt that we could
get smaller cameras closer to our actors
so we felt like shooting digitally
wouldn't affect our performance but
still gave us that size that scale that
dimension that scope that we were after
how many men on that crawler crew of 21.
our ships can take six each and still
three short
we'll find a way
from a color perspective denis wanted
ericus to be harsh and desolate and part
of that was we tried to never make the
sky blue we tried to say yellowy washed
out sand and then white sky
chill generators were 100 kilos each
yes gurney have our escorts throw out
their shield generators yes sir and paul
i want you at the back of the thought
guide them in delta ajax niner put seven
men each in my ships now
i wanted the light to have that quality
and i knew that greg was totally the one
that could bring that to the movie and
the thing is we decided that the movie
will be that we will use the imax format
for the dream sequence and the desert
we based our ratio on how does paul feel
when paul arrives in arakas the world
opens up so we're trying to mimic paul's
existence at that point
[Music]
just to be in that expansive space dunes
and mountains as far as the eye can see
such a beautiful place to be
where are they sir there's protocol for
a reason we take one step out there as
good as
damn the spice i want every man off that
crawler now
being in the desert was such a
transformative experience because it
made us feel how small you can feel as a
human in the vastness of the desert but
also be in relation with the sun with
the sand
[Applause]
please
there was a moment in jordan paul is
kneeling in front of the spice harvester
and he wanted annealing in front of it
to be really specific and uh eventually
he just showed it to me like no no it's
it's it's it's like this and then into
the sand you know like ask paula tradies
and uh
that was awesome because in that moment
i went he has his finger on the pulse of
paul
which is a good feeling
get up
let's go
what's the matter with you come on let's
go
when you take the decision to make dune
and you go back home the first thing you
say to yourself what about the worms
which is the big challenge
i really love the scene where they first
go out into the desert and they see a
worm attack it has to be very carefully
timed and we very carefully crafted that
it was a collaboration really between me
and denny but also with sam hudecki the
storyboard artist that we would compare
notes and try and kind of get the thing
in really good shape before they
actually shot the real action
we tried to approach the worm with the
same concerns that frank herbert wrote
and created the worm which is like a
biology how this creature adapted to
this environment and how it feeds are it
ants how it moves how it behaves it all
came from that feeling that the worm
will need to look like a survivor to the
edges and that it will have that kind of
prehistoric quality that it will have
the scales and that kind of very rough
skin that has been grinded by the sand
through centuries the sand worm was
unique in that we were concentrating on
the mechanics of the movement we studied
real world desert camouflaged creatures
to understand how they
would interact with their own
environments and we tried to apply some
of those lessons to how these sound
worms might function
we had to work very closely with our
visual effects vendors to understand how
sand might propagate if a giant creature
is pushing its way through folding sand
dunes the sand collapse in the vacuum
behind it or does it maintain as a mound
above it and we had to spend months
understanding how a worm of that size
would move through a huge field of sand
and finding the balance between the
artistic goals and what the real world
mechanics might be
hey
one of my closest collaborations in
editing is the sound department and i
wanted as an editor to be able to build
that sound world into this film right
from the outset and bake it in so i was
collaborating with the sound department
while we were filming the sounds of the
worm chase the sounds of the
ornithopters all these were being
developed in tandem with the filming
process
sand itself in large masses at the right
humidity makes these beautiful
whale-like groans and it almost makes
the desert like it's its own character
because it has a voice and we wanted to
bring those kinds of sounds to the movie
it was also hearing those sounds kind of
suggested what
the sound of a worm underneath the sand
might sound like
the first thing i tried doing was
sticking a microphone underneath the
sand and i realized that a sand dune is
a resonant body you can hear someone
walking 100 meters away so we then
headed out and recorded the real desert
as much as we could
the fremen think of the desert as
beautiful and i didn't want to make a
harsh scary over-the-top desert i wanted
the sounds to be beautiful so one of my
suggestions was to put in ocean waves
when the sand is moving with the sand
worms so that was a way that you can
change the character of an environment
into something beautiful from something
maybe terrifying or scary when you're
sitting in a theater and you hear sand
blowing and moving and things in the
wind all around you you're put inside
this environment that's a very important
part of what we do
the maker and his water
bless the coming and going of him
may his passage cleanse the world
and keep the world for his people
we'll keep found memories of our shoots
in the desert those memories will stay
in my mind for the rest of my life it
was by far probably one of the most
exciting and beautiful shoot i had and
it was a great adventure and
i had the
amazing room yeah
you